Je me considère vraiment comme un narrateur.
Mais je ne raconte pas les histoires de manière classique,
dans le sens où je ne raconte pas mes propres histoires.
Par contre, je suis très intéressé par la construction d'outils qui permettent
à un grand nombre de personnes de raconter leurs histoires,
quelles que soient leurs origines.
Je le fais parce que je pense que les gens ont beaucoup en commun.
Je pense que les gens se ressemblent beaucoup,
mais je pense aussi que nous avons du mal à le voir.
Vous savez, lorsque je regarde tout autour de moi, je vois beaucoup de différences,
et je pense que nous voyons tous beaucoup de différences.
Nous nous définissons par nos différences.
Vous savez, il y a des différences linguistiques,
des différences ethniques et raciales, des différences d'âge,
des différences de sexe, des différences d'orientation sexuelle,
des différences de richesse, des différences d'éducation,
il y a aussi des différences religieuses.
Vous savez, nous avons tous ces différences et je pense que nous aimons nos différences,
parce qu'elles nous font nous identifier à quelque chose,
à une petite communauté.
Mais je pense qu'en réalité, malgré nos différences,
nous avons vraiment beaucoup de choses en commun.
Et je pense que ce que nous avons en commun,
c'est un besoin très profond de nous exprimer.
Je pense que c'est un désir très ancien. Ce n'est pas nouveau.
Mais en ce qui concerne l'expression de soi,
il y a toujours eu ce déséquilibre
entre le désir que nous avons de nous exprimer
et le nombre d'amis sympathiques
qui sont prêts à être là et à écouter.
(Rires)
Ça aussi, ce n'est pas nouveau.
Depuis l'aube de l'histoire humaine, nous avons essayé de corriger ce déséquilibre
à travers l'art, l'écriture de poèmes, la chanson,
l'écriture de scripts éditoriaux et leur publication dans un journal,
les bavardages avec des amis. Ce n'est pas nouveau.
La nouveauté, c'est que depuis ces dernières années
beaucoup de ces activités traditionnelles à l'homme, très physiques,
ces actes d'auto-expression, sont passés sur Internet.
Et ce qui s'est passé, c'est que les gens ont laissé derrière eux des empreintes,
des empreintes qui racontent les histoires de leurs instants d'auto-expression.
Et donc, voilà ce que j'ai fais, j'ai écrit des programmes informatiques
qui étudient de larges échantillons de ces empreintes,
et ensuite, j'ai essayé d'en tirer des conclusions sur les personnes qui les ont laissées --
ce qu'ils ressentent, ce qu'ils pensent,
ce qui est différent dans le monde d'aujourd'hui par rapport à d'habitude.
Ce genre de questions.
Un projet qui explore ces idées
a été lancé il y a environ un an,
et est intitulé We Feel Fine (nous nous sentons bien).
C'est un outil qui, tous les deux ou trois minutes,
scanne les nouveaux posts de blog dans le monde
pour les occurrences des mots "I feel" (je ressens) ou "I am felling" (je me sens)
Et quand il trouve l'une de ces phrases,
il la capture à la virgule près,
puis tente automatiquement d'en déduire l'âge, le sexe
et la situation géographique de la personne qui a écrit cette phrase.
Puis, connaissant la situation géographique et la date,
nous pouvons alors trouver le temps qu'il faisait quand
cette personne a écrit la phrase.
Toutes ces informations sont enregistrées dans une base de données
qui collecte environ 20.000 sentiments par jour.
Il fonctionne depuis environ un an et demi.
Il a rassemblé actuellement environ 7,5 millions de sentiments humains,
et je vais vous donner un aperçu
de la façon dont cette information est alors visualisée. Voici donc We Feel Fine.
Ce que vous voyez ici est une masse grouillante de particules,
chacune d'elle représentant un sentiment humain unique
qui a été exprimé dans les dernières heures.
La couleur de chaque particule correspond au type de sentiment qu'il contient -
de sorte que, les sentiments positifs soient de couleurs vives.
Et les sentiments négatifs de couleur sombre.
Le diamètre de chaque point
représente la longueur de la phrase,
les gros points contiennent de grandes phrases,
et les petits points contiennent des petites phrases.
Tout point peut être cliqué et élargi. Nous voyons ici,
"Je me sentirais beaucoup mieux
si je pouvais me blottir dans ses bras en ce moment et sentir son affection pour moi
dans l'étreinte de son corps et la tendresse de ses lèvres"
Ainsi, les choses deviennent un peu chaudes, parfois
dans le monde des émotions humaines.
Et tout cela est exprimé par des personnes :
"Je sais que objectivement, ça ne signifie vraiment pas grand chose,
mais après avoir passé tant d'années comme un petit poisson dans un grand étang,
il est agréable de se sentir encore plus grand."
Les points montrent des qualités humaines. Ils ont comme leurs propres lois physiques,
et ils fourmillent, égarés, comme en train d'explorer le monde de la vie.
Et puis, ils montrent aussi la curiosité.
Vous pouvez voir quelques-uns de ces spécimens qui nagent autour du curseur en ce moment.
Vous pouvez en voir quelques autres
qui fourmillent autour du coin inférieur gauche de l'écran
autour de six mots. Ces six mots représentent les six mouvements
de We Feel Fine. Nous regardons actuellement Madness (la folie).
Il y a aussi Mumurs, Montage, Mobs, Metric et Mounds.
Et je vais vous guider à travers quelques-uns d'entre eux.
Murmurs fait s'envoler tous les sentiments.
Et puis, un par un, par ordre chronologique inverse,
ils s'excusent, entrant dans la liste déroulante des sentiments.
"Je me sens un peu mieux maintenant."
(Rires)
"Je me sens confus et incertain de ce que je veux faire."
"Je me sens dépouillé de quelque chose de génial ici."
"Je me sens libre, je me sens si bien."
"Je me sens comme si j'étais dans le brouillard de la dépression, que je ne peux quitter"
Et vous pouvez cliquer sur n'importe quelle phrase
et visiter le blog d'où elle provient. Et de cette manière,
vous pouvez prendre contact avec les auteurs de ces déclarations,
si vous sentez une certaine empathie.
Le mouvement suivant est appelé Montage.
Montage concerne tous les sentiments qui sont contenus dans les photographies,
ils sont extraits, et s'affichent dans une grille.
Cette grille est sensée représenter en image les sentiments du monde entier
pendant ces dernières heures, si vous voulez.
On peut cliquer sur chacun d'eux et les ouvrir.
On peut voir, "J'ai l'impression que je n'aurais du plaisir
que s'il est partagé" ça a été écrit par quelqu'un du Michigan.
On peut voir "Je me sens comme si j'avais été devant un ordinateur toute la journée"
(Rires)
Ils sont automatiquement construits en utilisant les objets trouvés:
"Je n'ai plus faim"
Le mouvement suivant est appelé mobs.
Mobs prévoit différentes ventilations statistiques
de la population des sentiments du monde de ces dernières heures.
On voit que "mieux" est le sentiment le plus fréquent en ce moment,
suivi par bon, mauvais, coupable, droit, bas, malade et ainsi de suite.
On peut également obtenir une ventilation par sexe.
On peut voir que dans ces dernières heures, les femmes ont été légèrement plus enclines
à parler de leurs émotions que les hommes.
Nous pouvons faire une répartition par âge, ce qui nous donne un histogramme
de la distribution émotionnelle du monde selon l'âge.
On voit que les gens qui ont la vingtaine sont les plus prolifiques,
suivis des adolescents, et ensuite les gens qui ont la trentaine,
et très peu de monde au delà.
Par beau temps, les sentiments suivent les caractéristiques physiques
de la météo qu'ils représentent,
de sorte que celles recueillies lors d'une journée ensoleillée
tourbillonnent comme s'ils faisaient partie du soleil.
Les plus nuageux flottent comme s'ils étaient dans le vent.
Les pluvieux tombent, comme si c'était une averse,
et les neigeux tombent sur le sol.
Enfin, la localisation pousse les sentiments à se positionner
sur une carte du monde, mettant en évidence leur répartition géographique.
Metrics fournit des vues numériques sur les données.
Nous voyons que le monde "se sent" actuellement utilisé
à 3,3 fois le niveau normal.
(Rires)
La sensation de chaleur est à 2,9 fois le niveau normal, et ainsi de suite.
D'autres vues sont également disponibles.
Voici le sexe, l'âge, la météo, l'emplacement.
Le dernier mouvement est appelé Mounds.
Il est un peu différent des autres.
Mounds permet de visualiser l'ensemble des données, des "blobs" gélatineux
qui en quelque sorte se trémoussent.
Et si je tiens mon curseur vers le bas, ils font une petite danse.
On voit que "mieux" est le sentiment le plus fréquent, suivi de "mauvais".
Et puis, si je le déplace ici, la liste commence à défiler,
et il y a effectivement des milliers de sentiments qui ont été collectés.
Vous pouvez voir que le petit curseur rose se déplacer en longueur,
il représente notre position.
Ici nous voyons des gens qui se sentent "glissants", "nauséeux", "responsables".
Il y a aussi une possibilité d'effectuer des recherches,
si vous êtes intéressé par une population donnée.
Par exemple, vous pourriez trouver des femmes d'une vingtaine d'année
qui se sentent "accro" alors qu'il fait nuageux au Bangladesh.
(Rires)
Mais je vais vous épargner ça.
Voici donc certains de mes montages préférés qui ont été recueillis:
"Je sens tellement mon père vivant en moi qu'il n'y a même plus de place pour moi."
"Je me sens très seule."
"J'ai besoin d'être dans un village de campagne
afin de me sentir belle."
"J'ai le sentiment d'être invisible pour toi."
"Je ne l'aurais pas caché, si la société ne m'a pas fait sentir combien j'en avais besoin."
"J'aime Carolyn." "Je me sens si vilain."
"Je sens que ces gens bizarres sont en réalité un plus de la vie au collège"
(Rires)
"J'aime comment je me sens aujourd'hui."
Donc, comme vous pouvez le constater, We Feel Fine utilise une technique
que j'appelle "l'observation passive.
Ce que je veux dire par là c'est qu'il observe passivement les gens,
comme ils vivent leur vie. Il scanne les blogs du monde entier
et examine ce que les gens ont écrit,
et ces gens ne savent pas qu'ils sont observés ou interrogés.
Et grâce à ça,
vous finissez par être très honnête, franc, sincère
et les réponses sont souvent très émouvantes.
C'est une technique que j'apprécie généralement dans mon travail
parce que les gens ne savent pas qu'ils sont interrogés.
Ils vivent simplement leur vie - et ils finissent par agir comme ça.
Une autre technique consiste à interroger directement les gens.
Et c'est une technique que j'étudie dans un projet différent,
Yahoo! Time Capsule,
qui a été conçu pour prendre une empreinte du monde en 2006.
Il était divisé en dix thèmes très simples -
l'amour, la colère, la tristesse et ainsi de suite -
dont chacun contenait une seule question, très ouverte,
posée au monde: Qu'est-ce que vous aimez ? Qu'est-ce qui vous met en colère ?
Qu'est ce qui vous rend triste ? En quoi croyez-vous ? Et ainsi de suite.
La "Time Capsule" a été disponible pendant un mois en ligne,
traduite en 10 langues, et voici à quoi elle ressemblait.
C'est un globe en rotation,
dont la surface est entièrement composée d'images,
de mots et de dessins de personnes
qui les ont soumis à la "Time Capsule".
Les dix thèmes se propagent et tournent autour de la "Time Capsule".
Vous pouvez passer en revue ces données et voir ce que les gens ont proposé.
Ceci est en réponse à Qu'est-ce qui est beau ? "Miss Monde".
Il y a deux modes à la "Time Capsule"
Il y a "One World" (Un Monde), qui présente le globe en rotation,
et "Many Voices" (Beaucoup de Voix) qui sépare les données en bandes de films
et vous permet de les passer en revue une par une.
Ce projet a été ponctué par un événement vraiment extraordinaire
qui a eu lieu dans le désert près d'Albuquerque au Nouveau Mexique
à la Jemez Pueblo, où pendant trois nuits consécutives,
le contenu de la capsule, était projeté sur les parois
des murs antiques de Red Rock Canyon,
hauts de 200 pieds. C'était vraiment incroyable.
Et nous avons aussi projeté le contenu de la "Time Capsule"
sous forme de code binaire dans l'espace extra-atmosphérique en utilisant un laser de 35 watts.
Vous pouviez voir la ligne orange quitter le sol du désert,
avec un angle d'environ 45 degrés. C'était étonnant
parce que la première nuit, je regardais toute ces informations
et j'ai vraiment commencé à voir les différences dont j'ai parlé plus tôt -
les différences d'âge, le sexe et la richesse et ainsi de suite.
Mais, vous savez, pendant que je le regardais encore, encore et encore,
et que je voyais ces images aller à travers les rochers,
j'ai réalisé que je voyais les mêmes archétypes
représentés encore, encore et encore.
Vous savez : mariages, naissances, funérailles, la première voiture, le premier baiser,
le premier chameau ou cheval - selon la culture.
C'était très émouvant. Cette photo là a été prise
la dernière nuit d'une falaise éloigné d'environ deux miles,
où le contenu de la capsule était projeté dans l'espace.
Et il y avait quelque chose de très émouvant
à propos de cette expression humaine envoyée dans le ciel nocturne.
Ça a commencé à me faire penser à beaucoup de choses sur le ciel nocturne,
et comment les humains l'ont toujours utilisé
pour projeter leurs grandes histoires.
Vous savez, quand j'était enfant dans le Vermont, dans là ferme où j'ai grandi,
je regardais souvent le ciel sombre
et je voyais la ceinture d'étoiles d'Orion, le chasseur.
Et en tant qu'adulte, j'ai été plus au courant
des grands mythes grecs qui se jouent dans le ciel tous les soirs.
Vous savez, Orion face au taureau rugissant.
Persée volant au secours d'Andromède.
Zeus battant Chronos pour le contrôle du mont Olympe
Je veux dire, ce sont les grands récits des Grecs.
Et ça m'a fait m'interroger sur notre monde d'aujourd'hui.
Et Je me suis demandé précisément,
si nous pouvions faire de nouvelles constellations aujourd'hui,
A quoi ressembleraient-elles ? Que seraient-elles ?
Si nous pouvions faire de nouveaux dessins dans le ciel, que dessinerions-nous ?
Quelles sont les grandes histoires d'aujourd'hui ?
Ce sont ces questions qui ont inspiré mon nouveau projet,
qui fait ses débuts aujourd'hui à TED.
Personne n'avait encore vu ça, publiquement.
Ça s'appelle "Universe" (Univers), et ça révéle notre mythologie moderne.
Il utilise cette métaphore d'un ciel nocturne interactif.
Donc, c'est mon grand plaisir maintenant de vous le montrer.
Universe commencera ici.
Et vous verrez qu'il mène avec un champ de déplacement étoiles,
et il y a une aurore boréale dans le fond,
une sorte de morphing de couleur. La couleur de l'aurore boréale
peut être contrôlé à l'aide de cette seule barre de couleur en bas,
et nous la mettrons ici en rouge.
Donc, vous voyez ces étoiles qui se déplacent.
Maintenant, ce ne sont pas juste des petits points de lumière, des petits pixels.
Chacune de ces étoiles représente en fait
un événement précis dans le monde réel -
une citation qui a été dite par quelqu'un, une image,
des nouvelles, une personne, une entreprise. Vous savez,
une sorte de personnalité héroïque.
Et vous remarquerez peut-être que, comme le curseur commence
à toucher certaines de ces étoiles, des formes commencent à émerger.
Nous voyons ici qu'il y a un petit homme marchant, ou peut-être une femme.
Et nous voyons ici, une photographie avec une tête.
Vous pouvez commencer à voir les mots émergeant ici.
Et ce sont les constellations ;
ce sont les constellations d'aujourd'hui.
Et je peux les allumer toutes,
et vous pouvez les voir se déplacer dans le ciel maintenant.
C'est l'univers de 2007, les deux derniers mois.
Ces données couvrent
des milliers de sources de nouvelles dans le monde.
Il s'agit d'utiliser l'API d'une société vraiment super avec qui je travaille
à New York, en fait, appelée Daylife.
Et c'est un peu une vue à la Zeitgeist à ce niveau
de la mythologie courante du monde au cours des deux derniers mois.
Ainsi nous pouvons voir où il est train de naître, comme le président Ford,
l'Irak, Bush. Et nous pouvons en fait isoler seulement les mots -
je les appelle les "secrets" - et nous pouvons les amener à former
une liste alphabétique. Et nous voyons que Anna Nicole Smith
a joué un grand rôle récemment.
Le président Ford - il s'agit des funérailles de Gerald Ford.
Nous pouvons en fait cliquer sur quoi que ce soit dans Universe
et le faire devenir le centre de l'univers,
et tout le reste entrera dans son orbite.
Donc, nous allons cliquer sur Ford, et maintenant cela devient le centre.
Et les choses qui se rapportent à Ford entrent dans son orbite
et tourbillonnent autour de lui.
Nous pouvons isoler seulement les photographies, et nous les voyons maintenant.
On peut cliquer sur l'une d'elles
et avoir cette photo au centre de l'univers.
Maintenant les choses qui s'y rapportent tourbillonnent autour.
On peut cliquer sur ce point et nous voyons cette image iconique
de Betty Ford embrassant le cercueil de son mari.
Dans l'univers, il n'y a pas de fin. Il s'étend à l'infini,
et vous n'avez qu'à cliquer sur des trucs.
Il s'agit d'une représentation photographique, appelé Snapshots.
Mais on peut en fait être plus précis dans la définition de notre univers.
Donc, si nous le voulons,
regardons à quoi l'univers de Bill Clinton ressemble.
Et voyons, durant cette dernière semaine, ce qu'il a fait.
Alors maintenant, nous avons un nouvel univers, restreint
aux choses concernant Bill Clinton.
Nous pouvons avoir ses constellations qui apparaissent ici.
Nous pouvons extraire ses secrets,
et on voit qu'il y a beaucoup de candidats,
Hillary, les présidentielles, Barack Obama.
Nous pouvons voir les histoires
auxquelles Bill Clinton participe en ce moment.
Toutes peuvent être ouvertes.
Ainsi, nous voyons Obama et les Clinton se rencontrant en Alabama.
Vous pouvez voir qu'il s'agit d'une histoire importante,
il ya beaucoup de choses dans son orbite. Si nous ouvrons ceci,
nous obtenons des perspectives différentes sur cette histoire.
Vous pouvez cliquer sur chaque réponse et lire l'article
à la source. Celui-ci est d'Al-Jazira.
Nous pouvons aussi voir les superstars. Ce serait les gens
qui sont un peu des héros et des héroïnes
qui apparaissent dans l'univers de Bill Clinton. Donc il y a Bill Clinton, Hillary,
l'Irak, George Bush, Barack Obama, Scooter Libby -
c'est le genre de personnes autour de Bill Clinton.
Nous pouvons aussi voir une carte du monde, donc cela nous montre la portée géographique
de Bill Clinton durant la dernière semaine.
Nous pouvons voir que c'est centré sur l'Amérique
parce qu'il y a fait campagne, sans doute,
mais il y a un peu d'action ici dans le Moyen-Orient.
Et puis on peut voir aussi une chronologie.
Nous voyons donc qu'il était un peu discret le samedi,
mais il était de retour au travail le dimanche matin,
et puis ça s'est réduit depuis, cette semaine.
Et ce n'est pas limité à des personnes ou des dates,
mais nous pouvons actuellement le filtrer par concepts.
Donc, si je mets le changement climatique pour l'ensemble de 2006,
nous allons voir à quoi cet univers ressemble.
Ici, nous avons notre champ d'étoiles, ici nous avons nos formes,
ici nous avons nos secrets.
Donc, nous voyons encore, le changement climatique est important.
Nairobi, conférence mondiale, l'environnement.
Et il y a également des citations que vous pouvez voir,
si vous êtes intéressé par les citations sur le changement climatique.
Vous savez, c'est vraiment une chose infinie.
Les superstars du changement climatique en 2006 :
les Etats-Unis, la Grande-Bretagne, la Chine. Vous savez,
ce sont les pays imposant qui définissent ce genre de concept.
Donc, c'est un outil qui demande à être d'exploré.
Ce sera en ligne dans quelques jours, probablement mardi prochain.
Et vous serez tous en mesure de l'utiliser et d'explorer
ce que votre mythologie personnelle pourrait être.
Vous remarquerez que, dans Daylife - plutôt, dans Universe,
cela soutient aussi bien la notion d'une mythologie mondiale,
qui est représentée par quelque chose d'aussi large que, disons, 2007,
qu'une mythologie personnelle.
Pendant que vous recherchez ce qui est important pour vous dans votre monde,
vous pouvez voir à quoi les constellations vont ressembler.
Ça a été un plaisir. Merci beaucoup. Merci.
(Applaudissements)